We want to find factors of 10 that sum to negative 7. Well, the two factors must
be negative 2 and negative 5. We can rewrite the middle term using minus 2x and
minus 5x, from these factors. Then, we do our factoring by grouping and our
final answer is x minus 5 times x minus 2. This stuff right here is the
trickiest part. We need to factor out a negative 5 from both of these terms. If
I factor out a negative 5 from positive 10, I'm left with negative 2. Remember
that you can check your work by distributing. This allows us to be sure that
we've done factoring by grouping correctly. Moving this way would be factoring,
so if we distribute, we would be undoing that process. Nice work with your
negative numbers and your factoring if you got that one correct.